Game of Thrones as an epic fantasy
packed with details and that means some
of those details are bound to leave
viewers puzzled now and then well you
don't need to find a maester to get your
answers because here's a spoiler filled
explanation of the most confusing Game
of Thrones moments it's never really
been clear exactly what brands powers
are as the three-eyed Raven we know you
can see events in the past the Noddy can
warg into animals and sometimes people
that control them and see current events
in the finale though he also seems to
imply you can see the future will you
lead the seven kingdoms to the best of
your abilities from this day on until
your last day why do you think I came
all this way this isn't the first time
though back in season 7 he gave
Littlefinger's Valyrian dagger to Arya
which he needed to kill the night king
in fact way back in season 3 brands
friend the mentor Jojen Reed explained
that green seers like them can in fact
see the future or even bring some sight
seeing things that haven't happened yet
so how much has brand known about his
future and for how long it's impossible
to say just like everything else to do
with bran how
well we know if the end
Game of Thrones was filled with
prophecies from Daenerys seeing the
show's ending in a vision to Cersei
having the death of a children foretold
by a witch old will be their crowns cold
shrouds
and then there was Melisandre assertion
of the resurrected hero as or a hi would
ends the great darkness with his sword
and light bringer that one didn't come
true or did it according to law
aids or a high force light bringer by
stabbing his lover in the hearts just as
John dead with Daenerys like Melisandre
we all assume the prophecy was literal
but if it was just a metaphor that maybe
it did happen after all the war was the
shield that guarded the realms of men
and then at the end of season seven it
was destroyed by the night Kings undead
dragon allowing the dead to march into
Westeros and getting a dragon was a
lucky break for the night king -
otherwise he might have been stuck
banging his head against that wall
forever that's because the wall was made
using ancient magic that prevented White
Walkers from crossing its walls not just
ice and stone ancient spells were carved
into his foundations well this does the
dead cannot pass only the power of a
supernatural creature like the dragon
could break those spells and bring this
series to its inevitable conclusion at
the summit and the dragon pit at King's
Landing the lords and ladies of Westeros
do more than just choose a new king and
bran they also create the six kingdoms
of Westeros because Sansa just knope's
out the north will remain an independent
Kingdom as it was for thousands of years
so why didn't anyone else do that dawn
has a long history of semi-autonomy but
given the massive political upheaval the
murders of two consecutive rulers and
their heirs it makes sense for this
random new guy to make alliances where
he can Yara and the Iron Islands on the
other hand had already negotiated a
measure of autonomy with Queen Daenerys
what if everyone starts demanding their
independence she's not demanding she's
asking so there's no clear reason why
she would agree especially given her
enmity to what the Starks our guess is
that with the iron fleet destroyed house
Greyjoy is simply too weak to risk her
going alone for now that is seems like
bran is going to have a lot of work
ahead of him to keep this coalition
together when John was sent to join the
Nights Watch at the end of the final
episode even he had to ask one pressing
question still Night's Watch with the
night King destroyed the war than ruins
and the wildlings at peace with the
north it doesn't seem to be any purpose
to the Nights Watch so it's fitting that
Jon spends all the five seconds there
before heading even further north
with tormund and the wild Lynx what
their plans are is unknown but the wait
almond seems to defer him suggest very
strongly that John may take his new
place among the free focus
king-beyond-the-wall not a bad ending
after all the reunion of Sansa and Arya
Stark of Winterfell was one of the most
emotional moments of season seven but it
was quickly replaced by tension between
the sisters for the entire season if the
two characters were pitted against each
other by Littlefinger and then suddenly
in the last episode Arya and Sansa were
best friends again working together to
take him down most fans were left to
assume that they had done the obvious
thing and just asked bran of living
Wikipedia what was really going on the
show never spelled it out though or
rather they just never showed it to us
in fact Isaac Hempstead writes who plays
bran revealed in an interview that they
actually did film a scene where Sansa
asked Brown for the truth and he
uncovered Littlefinger's treachery the
scene never aired but if you're
wondering how and why the sisters
suddenly teamed up now you know after
Queen Daenerys of slain her right-hand
man grey worm demands justice leading to
Jon's exile and then grey worm takes you
and Sully to Nath Swilly barrage or not
if she felt like you missed something
here well you did well the show is never
actually show enough just for episodes
earlier gray Worman is doomed to love
Erma Sande discussed retiring to the
tropical beaches of her homeland
nah I'd like to see the beaches again
and I will take you there we're not sure
how the island does react to being
visited by an army of silent eunuchs but
here's hoping grey worms somehow finds a
happy ending which would be a game of
Thrones first check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos by your favorite shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]